parís ya tiene su primer gran centro de
vacunación contra la viruela del mono y
desde su apertura son cientos los
franceses que acuden buscando la
inoculación
hay mucha afluencia se llenaron todas
las citas que había hoy y ayer la gente
viene sin cita a pedir información a
preguntar cuándo podrían tener cita para
vacunarse entonces es bastante positivo
conocen esta enfermedad y quieren
vacunarse está a 6 voltios una función
de medellín y yo regidores es el xxi de
francia cuenta con menos de 2.000 casos
detectados del virus declarado como una
nueva amenaza sanitaria internacional
por la organización mundial de la salud
casos que se han detectado
principalmente entre la población lgp y
pumas y hombres jóvenes para mí es
importante vacunar me sobre todo porque
soy parte de la llamada población de
alto riesgo si podemos evitar la
propagación de una enfermedad y evitar
caer en una segunda pandemia sobre todo
porque apenas salimos del cob y de eso
estaría bien pero el miedo de los
colectivos lgtb
va más allá de la enfermedad también
temen al virus de la estigmatización y
la exclusión social
me provoca ansiedad tengo miedo todos
tenemos miedo de que ésta sea una nueva
versión del vih y que pueda ser una
especie de pretexto para la
discriminación
en todo el país se han abierto otros
pequeños lugares para vacunar a la
población de alto riesgo unas seis mil
personas ya han sido inoculadas a nivel
nacional nuestra posición es que debemos
abrir el mayor número de centros y
franjas horarias posibles un esfuerzo
para evitar que la viruela del mono se
convierta en otra pandemia a gran escala